tipping culture has gone too far we've
all seen this building for a long time
it happens everywhere any store you go
to you go to the cafe you go to the grab
Ando restaurant once it happened to me
at a donut shop the clerk is there and
you complete your transaction and then
he flips the iPad around and he says oh
just pess a few buttons plays Dumb do
whatever you want to do that's fine okay
yesterday this reached a whole new level
I was on my way to Cornell I spoke at
Cornell last night it's going to be
aired tonight on the yaf YouTube channel
but I'm on my way to Cornell I'm at the
airport there's a little store called
Cheo Express so I go in to get a drink
and there is no employee in the stop I I
go I reach in I say I want an IC tea
there's no I okay that's fine I get a
perryer so I I take it to the self
checkout kiosk and I
scan the
perryer and then it says to me how much
would you like to tip
there was nobody I could have tipped
there was only the robot the robot asked
me for a tip 18% 20% maybe
25% and now I'm kicking
myself because I did not tip even though
I'm fairly certain that the robots will
take over the whole country so
now that means I could have curried good
favor with our future robot overlords
but but instead I did not and so now I
am wait waiting for those random robot
overlords to come and exact their
Revenge I'm Michael nlls this the
Michael nlls
[Music]
Show
welcome back to the show huge story that
Steven Crowder broke about the manifesto
in Nashville we'll get to that in one
second also this episode is brought to
you by good ranchers claim your year of
free meat $15 off in free shipping with
my code nolles kwes at goodranchers.com
that is goodranchers.com promo code
nolles today my least favorite part
about being on the road that I cannot
eat good ranchers as much as I would
like to I also miss my wife and children
but part of being with my wife and
children a lot of the time is eating
good ranchers so look forward to that
when I get back home uh speaking of Law
and Order we'll get to the big story
obviously we'll get to the manifesto in
just a moment speaking of Law and Order
though I'm here at Cornell and Cornell
Just A Week Ago saw a kid make threats
against Jewish students here and say he
wants to kill all the Jewish men and do
horrible things to the Jewish women and
he's going to go start shooting people
and they found him they arrested him he
faces 5 years in prison for the threats
he's a 21-year-old he faces a quar
million doll fine he faces a term of
supervised release of up to three years
after he serves his prison sentence and
some people might suggest amid our
enthusiasm for free speech that this is
not great because it's a restriction on
speech and I might not support what you
say but I'll defend to the death your
right to say or whatever nonsense no of
course that is not the case nobody has
the right to make threats against people
people threats have never been protected
speech there are a lot of things that
have never been protected speech in
America obscenity liable all sorts of
other things too this is the subject of
my book
speechless no okay all right on the road
they don't they don't have it here at
Cornell uh but I have no problem with
the cops arresting this kid for making
threats against Jewish students my only
problem is that we don't do this more
broadly the same should go for threats
against Christian students threats
against conservatives threats against
people who mildly
criticize there are a lot of people in
America who receive all sorts of threats
and the cops do
nothing I've experienced this firsthand
Matt Walsh has experienced this probably
five to 10 times at least what I've
experienced in terms of people really
making ghastly threats against him and
the cops do nothing he reports it to the
cops they take it very seriously the
cops do nothing so I'm all
for uh Prosecuting these kinds of people
but the lesson we should learn here from
Cornell is that we don't do that nearly
enough and we ought to do it uh in
support of all sorts of politically
unpopular groups as well speaking of
freedom of speech really really sad
story out of Britain just after I flew
out of London just the day I think it
was the very day I flew back from London
this past week there was a massive Pro
Palestine protest in London there were
also some Pro British protesters so
while there were people waving the
Palestine flag there were people waving
the Union Jack and the people waving the
Union Jack were British military
veterans and the cops came up and told
them that they couldn't wave their flag
they didn't say that to the pro
Palestine protesters they said that to
the British military veterans here's
[Music]
why you can hold it you can hold it you
can wave it it's just we
don't any in the barriers have have your
flags just not on the barriers that's
it and yet when they March down with
hundreds of Palestinian Flags you won't
say at
word
out's way more of
them
more no it's displaying on these bar
barriers I know but he's driving a motor
we're talking about these barriers it's
not just the
barri was F CH the other day you didn't
do nothing did you I wasn't there no you
wasn't there but you didn't do nothing
and the veterans some of them wearing
their full military
fatigue at least the the younger cop or
the cop on the
left is saying yeah yeah it's not
fair but there's more of those guys than
there are of us so we can't put them in
their place their Flags we're going to
put you in your place cuz there aren't
that that many British military veterans
out
here very
very sad story that's democracy for you
I
guess that's he's saying yeah we're
overruled by the mob and so in your own
country British veterans who have risked
your lives to defend this island
nation you don't get the right to
political speech even the most basic
political speech which is to wave your
flag and support your country but those
guys or foreigners who are pledging
their allegiance to a foreign it's not
even a foreign Nation it's a a foreign
wouldbe Nation but at the very least
it's a foreign people they get the
political rights that you risked your
lives for the rights that you do not get
yourselves we need to pray for our
Nations around the West when you want to
pray one great way to do it is to check
out hallow right now go to hall.com nesk
Wes with everything going on in the
world there is no better time to build a
daily habit of prayer and meditation
building a habit of prayer can help you
cultivate an attitude of gratitude folks
focusing on what you are thankful for
can increase positive emotions and
improve overall well-being also you owe
it to God to pray so you should pray
hello is the number one Christian Prayer
app in the United States it's helped so
many people to maintain a daily prayer
routine it can help you too download the
app for free at hall.com you can set
prayer reminders and track your progress
along the way not sure where to start
check out father Mike schmitz's Bible in
a year available on the hallo app for
brief daily readings and Reflections or
pray alongside Mark Wahlberg Jim cisel
even some world-class athletes with
hallo you can customize a personal
prayer plan that works for you listen
wherever you are with downloadable
offline sessions using hallow to connect
with others who share your beliefs and
values can provide a sense of belonging
support and Foster a sense of community
Hall just added a section on their app
called prayers for peace for Israel they
have several prayers to help people pray
for peace in Israel download hall.com
KW get an exclusive 3 months free that
is 3 months absolutely free at hall.com
slns the decay of British democracy
reminds me of what reminds me of a clip
from that Indian Guru guy he had a
documentary made about him he's kind of
a cult leader here in America he he
has an increasingly persuasive theory on
Democracy democracy basically
means
government by the people of of the
people for the
people but the people are
that was the fear of our
founding fathers that was the fear of
the framers of our
constitution if you had too much
democracy it could turn into mob Rule
and pbus writes about this that the
decay of the good forms of government
monarchy aristocracy and democracy would
be tyranny oligarchy and mob rule when
the difference being that in the good
forms of government people are ruling
for the common good in the bad forms of
government they're ruling merely for
their
self-interest that's what we're seeing
here people ruling without any care for
the common good Great Britain the United
Kingdom who cares about that no you
don't even we don't even let the
military vets wave their
Flags but whatever hordes of foreigners
want to come in and wave the flags of
other peoples and other places yeah
that's fine why because there's more of
them than there are of us what a
condemnation now speaking of
democracy there's a new poll out from
New York Times and Sienna
College the libs are not going to like
this the people back in candidates other
than the front runner and the GOP
Primary for president are not going to
like this Trump is leading not only the
primary Challengers but he's leading Joe
Biden not just nationally but in
multiple States not just any states but
States so this according to the New York
Times where is it here we
go Nevada Trump 52 Biden 41
Georgia Trump 49 Biden 43 Arizona these
are all crucial States Trump 49 Biden 44
Michigan Trump 48 Biden
43 Pennsylvania even Trump 48 Biden
44 Wisconsin is the one
swing state listed here where Biden is
still winning 47 to 45 so you know
within two percentage points
statistically it's a dead
Heat this
shows what I have suspected from the
beginning which is that in a fair
election Donald Trump has a decent
chance of winning I'm not saying it's
guaranteed I'm not saying he's going to
win by a bazillion votes I'm not saying
he's going to win by a huge margin in
the Electoral College I'm just saying in
a fair election Donald Trump has a
decent chance of winning in a rigged
election he has a very weak chance of
winning and as of today it seems to me
that the election will still be fairly
rigged because they rigged it during
2020 they used CO as the excuse and they
changed the rules to favor Democrats and
to leave the possibility of ballot fraud
open and Democrats are better at
stuffing The Ballot Box than Republicans
are and they're better at stealing
elections than Republicans are so
right now it seems that the election
might be fairly rigged so if these
numbers are to be believed then the libs
are going to have to go even further to
rig the election and the way that
they're going to do that is that they're
going to delegitimize Trump and that has
been the strategy from the beginning
that's what all of these prosecutions
are about if they can get Trump on
federal charge is great if they can get
him on state charge is great if they can
say that he mishandled classified
documents and he's a traitor great if
they can say that he tried to steal the
election by calling the secretary state
of Georgia great if they can take away
his business great if they can say that
he got handsy with a gossip columnist 50
years ago they'll do that too it just
it's all about delegitimizing him as a
political person saying that it's it's
not even acceptable to consider voting
for him and so salon.com is is following
This Thread here and the argument
is far right Maga theocrats are the most
dangerous threat to
America so at a time shortly after Hamas
terrorists slaughtered over a thousand
Israeli civilians children women the
elderly at a time when the terror threat
is a little bit higher right now uh
salon.com is
countering this fact by saying no no you
think Hamas is bad you think Hezbollah
is bad no no no the the real threat or
the farri Maga people the way you know
you're they're trying to compare them to
the Muslims is they're they're calling
them Maga theocrats and whatever you
want to say about Donald
Trump he's not a theocrat right he's a
apparently lapsed
Presbyterian I don't think anyone has
ever said that Donald Trump is part of
the religious right you know he's
Marching In lock step with Jerry fwell
or some hard right Christian
conservative person far from it the
knock on Trump is that he's lived a kind
of Playboy libertine
lifestyle even though he's he's been
great and advanced a lot of Christian
priorities so that's why they say it's
the far-right magga theocrats but they
can't really go after Trump on it so
they've got to go after someone else
they previously would go after Mike
Pence but Pence is obviously long long
off the Trump train so now they're going
against Mike Johnson they're saying it's
the first line of the article even Mitch
McConnell is trying to push back against
Mike Johnson in the Maga wing of the GOP
it isn't
working and they go on and on and on
about uh the FBI issuing a warning of
Terror attacks and blah blah blah blah
blah but actually the real threat are
these nice Meek Christian
conservatives does anybody believe this
does anybody believe that nice Mike
Johnson or nice previously Mike Pence or
some just ordinary Christian
conservative is the biggest Terror
threat in
America
no
but if the Liberals can convince just
enough people in just enough positions
of
power that Donald Trump should not even
be considered for the presidency that
judges should try to disqualify him that
secretaries of State in the various
States should take him off the
ballot that big Tech should not platform
his dangerous speech
then maybe then uh the people won't have
a chance to vote for him then maybe then
the people won't have sufficient
information about the campaign then
maybe then they won't have to deal with
the problem that is glaring them in the
face from the polls the problem that
they've been trying to deny for years
now which is that Trump is popular that
people like him they thought he couldn't
possibly win in 2016 that's why they
encouraged him to be the GOP nominee
because he was going to be the easiest
one to be and then president Hillary was
was going to walk in and none of that
happened Trump won and so they said
yikes we can't let this happen again so
they rigged it in 20120 and now they're
trying to take him off the ballot if
they thought the guy would just lose at
The Ballot Box they wouldn't be trying
to delegitimize him in this way
now getting to the most important story
of the day this is the scoop of the year
and it comes from Steven Crowder this I
I would say that this is the biggest
scoop in three years five years it's
certainly up there it's in the top three
I think probably the biggest news scoops
of the last three four years were the
New York Times New York Times excuse me
they don't scoop anything they just
repeat the propaganda they hear from the
Biden Administration the the biggest
Scoops would be the New York Post with
the hunter Biden laptop
story I would say up there would be our
own story that we broke the Lowden
County in the school story that I think
did a lot to help get Glenn yunan
elected governor and that I think blew
the lid off a lot of the
propaganda and this story which I guess
is related to the propaganda story
Steven Crowder was able to get a leak of
the manifesto from the shooter who shot
up that Christian School here in
Nashville Tennessee and killed innocent
little children and the FBI didn't want
to release the manifesto because it
didn't fit the narrative the shooters
are supposed to be far right-wing there
supposed to be men Neo-Nazi Disturbed
men who listen to conservative media
that's what it's got to be and that
wasn't the case here in the case of the
Nashville shooter she was
a
leftist
who seems to have hated Christians seems
to have hated white people seems to have
hated conservatives seems to seems to
have bought into a left-wing narrative
and here's the evidence Accord according
to the leak which daily wire has said is
genuine we don't have confirmation
confirmation but certainly seems real
some of the quotes are kill those kids
three exclamation marks those crackers
going to private fancy schools with
those fancy khakis and sports backpacks
with their daddy's Mustangs and
convertibles there's a 28-year-old woman
who wrote in her diary on February 3rd
all those things I wish to shoot your
weak ass di KS with with your mop yellow
hair want to kill all you little
crackers bunch of little with your white
privileges that's another line from the
diary I hope I have a high death count
ready to die ha haa
okay this person is
obviously Disturbed possessed or at the
very least mentally
ill no question obviously the person's
mentally ill this woman so yes she
there's no doubt
but beyond the obvious mental illness
just the
language is this right-wing language or
leftwing language when some crazy
shooter shoots up a place and is quoting
Hitler or is quoting some right-wing
figure or whatever all the news are
going to report this is a far right-wing
ideologue speaking in Far right-wing
language and was inspired by the far
right-wing people well okay ask yourself
reading this
language crackers those private fancy
schools I want to shoot you little
crackers with your white privilege White
Privilege what kind of language is this
is this the language of a far right
winger or is this the language of a
leftist obviously a leftist this is
someone steeped in leftist ideology and
who engages in leftist Behavior that's
why there was a cover up that's why the
FBI refused to release this daily wire
requested this multiple times we were
shut down every step of the way the FBI
wanted to cover it up
because it it isn't a clear example
putting even the mental illness aside of
left-wing political violence that's why
right now after this leaked there was an
investigation that was announced into
the leaker the first thing the
authorities said was
not how do we prevent these attacks from
happening in the future it was not what
inspired this attacker no no no the
question was hey who let the cat out of
the bag hey hey who who told that this
was a left
Wier that's why because we this is only
a partial release but from the partial
leak we can see this is
consistently leftwing language not good
stuff now a little silver lining amid
the storm cloud of a lot of terrible
news would be delicious good ranchers
right now go to goodranchers.com use
promo code nolles you know there's a lot
at stake this November so don't be
chicken and shop at the grocery store
like usual instead you should Seafood
your way to I lost I lost thread go to
good ranchers their Black Friday uh your
way sale is live it's something you do
not want to miss they've got great meat
puns I've got great meat puns they've
got even better meat this November you
get to pick your favorite meat to get
free for a year pick a year of free
steak free salmon free chicken or free
bacon when you subscribe to any box
right now better yet when you subscribe
to any boox on goodranchers.com you not
only get a free gift of meat worth up to
$480 you also get 15 bucks off with code
nolles I don't know how their finances
work at good ranchers I don't know how
they Source meat this good it's just
phenomenal I eat good ranchers multiple
times a week when I'm not traveling on
the road it it's just magnificent
quality I've never had anything like it
the prices are unbelievable and then
they keep locking in your price and
giving you stuff for free and I don't
know how they do it uh but you should
sign up well you still can claim your
year of free meat 15 bucks off in free
shipping with my code nolles canes at
goodranchers.com goodranchers is the
number one place to get all American
Beef Pork Chicken and Seafood it is
promo code nolles atg goodranchers.com
goodranchers American Meat delivered you
know we made Jeremy's razors because we
were fed up with all the nonsense being
shouted from the woke Libs it's not just
the razors degree Dove native have all
joined in the woke culture but we're not
here to complain we're here to complain
a little bit but we're mostly here to
create alternative quality products that
match your expectations and resonate
with your values that is why we asked
the obvious question after releasing
Jeremy's razors what do you want from
Jeremy's next you made it clear with no
need for us to call in a specialized
research team to find out what you
wanted you wanted Jeremy's deodorant
okay well we're proud once again to give
you exactly what you asked for
introducing Jeremy's deodorant keeping
you safe from the pleasant smell of
liberalism we stick to the ingredients
you can trust and pronounce like cocoa
oil Coco oil it's coconut oil and Shea
Butter ingredients that make you smell
great but are not toxic to masculinity
with no room for aluminum
Fates I think I'm pronouncing that
correctly tal or ads with unattractive
models that no one needs to see topless
we care about what goes on your body
that is why our Jeremy's deodorant is
made up of simple ingredients no greasy
surprises no residue it's all new it's
available right now go to Jeremy
racers.car
not to be confused with the ASMR which
is the
American Society for medicine about
reproduction no that's not that would be
the ASMR this is the
asrm they have redefine the term
infertility so what is what is
infertility used to be pretty simple
right you just you're not able to
conceive the natural
way here's the new definition okay
infertility is a disease condition or
status characterized by any of the
following okay the inability to achieve
a successful pregnancy based on a
patient's medical sexual and
reproductive history age physical
findings diagnostic testing or any
combination of these factors so far okay
it seems generally okay the need for
medical intervention including but
unlimited to the use of donor gametes or
donor embryos in order to achieve a
success uccessful pregnancy either as an
individual or with a
partner okay okay I'm getting a little
weirder all
right in patients having regular
unprotected intercourse and without any
known etiology for either partner
suggestive of impaired reproductive
ability evaluation should be initiated
at 12 months when the female partner is
under 35 years of age and at 6 months
when the female partner is at 35 years
of age or older
okay that part seems generally okay so
hold on let's go back a little bit what
is this medical intervention need for
donor gametes or donor embryos in order
to to achieve successful pregnancy
because if your status and your sexual
history okay hold on wait are you
telling
me that homosexuals are now considered
infertile yes the asrm makes it
clear they say this is according to uh
Jared Robbins medical doctor this
revised definition reflects that all
persons regardless of marital status
sexual orientation or gender identity
deserve equal access to Reproductive
Medicine this inclusive definition helps
ensure that anyone seeking to build a
family has Equitable access to infertil
infertility treatment and care there it
is so there we get
it this gets to the very heart of the
so-called gay marriage debate I say
so-called because one gay marriage is
not real and two there never was a
debate what was the debate the debate
was what you don't think that gay people
should have the right to get married
that was no that was never the actual
subject of the debate a real debate over
redefining marriage would first begin
with the question What is marriage does
sexual difference have something to do
with marriage I talked about this last
night at
Cornell I think it probably has
something to do with marriage doesn't
it okay well if sexual difference is
intrinsic to marriage then there's no
such thing as gay marriage there can't
be because by definition two men could
not get married to one another and two
women could not get married to one
another homosexuals cannot be said to be
infertile by their
nature because two men never can produce
a baby together and two women never can
produce a baby together for all that the
libs love to talk about the need for
sexual education in the public schools
they don't seem to know the first two
things about it so why do they do this
they're doing this in part because
they've accepted the premise that men
and women are exactly the same and
they're IND discern IND discernable and
they're indistinguishable and they're
totally uh able to be substituted one
for the other which is a premise not
only of but also of the homosexual
movement and the feminist movement uh
but furthermore they're doing this so
that when there is some medical right
whether through private insurance or
through a government program to
reproductive health care that they're
going to offer it to the homosexuals and
they're going to allow homosexual
couples to purchase children like
Commodities like they're going out to
buy a handbag and what they're going to
do is thereby establish the domination
of technology and of the state over the
origin and Destiny of human life that's
what it's about nobody is seriously
confused by the meaning of
infertility no nobody is no homosexual
guy is going to the doctor saying doc me
and Billy we've been trying for 10 years
now to conceive a baby it's just not
working you know I mean we're we've
tried it a bunch of different ways and
there's no babies getting produced well
um let's run some tests I don't know Bob
why you and Billy aren't able to
conceive a no everyone knows everyone
knows that that's not how babies are
made so the left is doing what the left
always does which is to manipulate
language to attempt
to redefine Reality by changing the
words they they think that they can
change the meaning of the words the
thing that the words signify and at the
very least they think they can fool
everybody and force people to fool
themselves nobody really is
fooled all that will happen is we'll
live in lies and we'll all pretend and
will invert Society such that well at
this very basic level no longer are
parents there to nurture their children
but actually the the children are just
there to nurture and entertain their
parents no longer are children the the
product of love between a mother and a
father who whose love is so real that it
becomes another person but the children
are just something to be bought from
scientists and the state like a handbag
or a new watch turning our attention now
to very fertile people Hunter Biden
Hunter Biden has a new oped in USA
Today headline is I fought to get sober
political weaponization of my addiction
hurts more than me my struggles and my
mistakes have been fodder for a vile and
sustained disinformation campaign
against my father and an all that
annihilation of my
reputation hunter in US say today okay
here are the key parts and this tells
you a lot about where the bidens are he
says my struggles and my mistakes have
been fodder for this viol and sustained
disinformation campaign against Biden
and all out annihilation of my
reputation through high-pitched but
fruitless Congressional investigations
hold on put a pause there fruitless we
got the Smoking Gun we got the we got
the confirmation from you that you are
the bagman for the Biden family that you
shake down leaders around the world
selling American influence that you get
money from them and then you pay at
least 10% if not 50% of it to the big
guy fruitless investigations we know
that you had these Shady business deals
wired to you using your father's address
as the beneficiary address fruitless
investigations fruit totally fruitless
and more recently he writes criminal
charges for possessing an unloaded gun
for 11 days 5 years ago charges that
appear to be the first of their kind
ever brought in the history of Delaware
yeah you you were being charged for that
because the prosecutors were giving you
a sweetheart deal to not charge you for
any of the serious crimes the serious
crimes of public interest go Way Beyond
the gun charge the serious crimes of
public interest go to racketeering
serious crimes of public interest go to
failing to register as a foreign agent
serious crimes of foreign interest
involve your father getting bribed when
he was the vice president of the United
States these are these charges these are
trumped up charges yeah because they
didn't bring any of the real charges
against you this was the way to get you
off the hook bro then he goes on and
this is the key what troubles me forget
about me it's not just about attacks on
me Hunter no no what troubles me is the
demonization of
addiction of human Frailty using me as
its Avatar and the devastating
consequences it has for the millions
struggling with addiction desperate for
a way out and being
bombarded by the denigrating a near
constant coverage of me and my addiction
on Fox News more airtime than GOP
Presidential candidate Ronda santis gets
and in the New York Post an average of
two stories a day over the past year
yeah because the New York sto the New
York Post broke the story not just of
your addiction and all the weird photos
and videos that you put on your computer
that you took yourself and that you left
at this repair shop and it was
suppressed by big
Tech but of your crimes your financial
and political crimes this oped to me is
so desperate for a man who Hunter
Biden's done a lot of desperate things
this to me seems like the most desperate
example they got this guy dead and by
they I mean we the conservatives we've
got this guy dead to rights on
corruption this is his last ditch ever
to say hey it's it's addiction I'm
suffering from a disease yeah I listen I
I know addicts addiction is very hard
it's hard to get over addiction to
alcohol or drugs or
but it's look we make jokes about it you
make jokes about political people oh
yeah this one's a little fat this one's
a little bit of a Booz Hound this one's
woman eyes or but
it's man it's all of it it's all of it
it's the it's the
hookers and it's the crack sure and it's
the but more than that it's the it's the
painting you took up painting and now
you're selling your artwork for half a
million dollars a piece for your Doodles
your little Doodles that you do that a
5-year-old could do I'm not making fun
of your art Hunter Biden I'm making fun
of your of your graft I'm making fun of
your con because art collection first of
all is one of the most prominent and
well-known avenues for money laundering
that there is and nobody thinks that
your ridiculous Doodles are worth half a
million dollars it's obviously just a
way to keep the con going now that
you've got a little more attention on
you and it's hard for you to go shake
down CCP officials in China or oligarchs
in
Ukraine but it's also the pitching up 10
for the the big
guy it's also the introducing Joe to
your business partner and then Joe your
father while he's vice president saying
to your business partner I'm really glad
you and Hunter hooked up yeah that's
good I hope you enjoyed that lunch with
the president of China today yeah yeah I
hope you guys do good business together
it's your father calling into 20 plus
phone calls it's your father sending
tens of thousands of emails under
pseudonyms when he was vice president of
the United States many of which were
were to conduct business with your
business partner in your shady overseas
contacts they got this guy dead to
rights and the best thing he can do is
say
hey you're mocking
addicts this is like John fedman when
John anytime you criticize John fedman
he says you're mocking stroke victims
mocking stroke first of all man people
were mocking John fedman long before his
stroke two if you have had a stroke and
you you're mentally debilitated you
should resign from the Senate it's no
knock on you it's not to say you're an
immoral person because you've had a
health problem but you're just not up to
the job and you should
resign but three no one does not mock
stroke victims broadly one goes after
you because you're a kid who kid he's a
grown man obviously now but since he was
a kid he never really had that serious a
job he was getting handouts from Mom and
Dad he had a radical political agenda
he's not the workingclass hero he pres
presented himself as that's what people
are and whenever people knock him for
any reason he oh it's you're just
knocking me for my disability same thing
here with Hunter Biden even more
ridiculous from Hunter Biden okay this
is a story we got to turn our attention
away from Bad fathers in politics bad
fatherson combos to good fatherson
combos there is a ridiculous attack
right now on Mike Johnson the new
Republican Speaker of the House Rolling
Stone Rolling Stone one of the truly
degenerate Publications out there
rolling stone which had to change its
headline defaming me after the daily
wire made legal demands of them and
after a sitting United States Senator
Senator Mike Lee also said that I had a
good case against These Guys these types
of journalists Rolling Stone changed a
defamatory headlines so they don't have
a lot of uh journalistic
credibility Rolling Stone
attacks Republican speaker Mike Johnson
for being a good father which we'll get
to in one second first though speak
speaking of health and raising your
family and treating your body the right
way you got to go check out Medishare
right now go to medishare.com
as a dailywire listener you are not just
informed you're engaged and you're
handsome too you value freedom and
personal responsibility that's why you
got to check out Medishare Medishare is
a community-based approach to healthcare
that lines up with the principles you
believe in your beliefs matter with
Medishare your Healthcare dollars won't
be used for medical procedures that
don't line up with your beliefs
Medishare is the highest rated
Healthcare sharing Ministry with a
30-year proven track record it's not
health insurance it's a community of
400,000 Believers committed to caring
and sharing with one another members
save up to 50% or more on their monthly
healthcare costs and member satisfaction
surveys show that they like medish share
much more than health insurance why
because it works for a limited time
dailywire listeners will receive a $150
gift card when they join meta share to
find out more go to medishare.com m AEL
that is medishare.com
micel and you will receive a
$150 gift card when you join Medishare
terms and conditions apply my favorite
comment yesterday is from the drummers
Workshop Norms music who says graduating
from Trump University would be cool
because you can say it was your allma
Maga you know that I'm a sucker for a
good pun that's a very good pun that's
that's another reason to to promote the
new American Academy initiative under
Trump is then you can some PE the libs
have their Alma mat and you will have
your Alma M
MAA Rolling Stone runs this headline
they say Speaker of the House Mike
Johnson admitted that he and his son
monitored each other's porn intake in a
resurfaced clip from 2020 whoa wow man
that's gross and weird isn't it
wow that's what kind of weird stuff is
the Republican speaker into what the
hold on well let's just listen because
we have the
clip here here's what actually
happened Covenant eyes is the software
that I I've we've been using a long time
in our household and what it is it's
accountability software so uh men in a
church you know men's bible study groups
will do it that's how it was presented
at promis Keepers but they also mention
hey when your kids become teenagers
especially if you have boys dads they're
talking to the guys at this event you
might want to think about doing this
with your sons it scans you you
obviously opt into it but it scans every
all the activity on your phone or your
devices your laptop tablet what have you
we do all of it and then it sends a
report to your accountability partner so
my account accountability partner right
now is Jack my son right and so he's 17
so he and I get a report of all the
things that are on our phones or all of
our devices once a week if anything
objectionable comes up your
accountability partner gets an immediate
notice I'm proud to tell you my son is
he's got a clean slate all right but but
we get we get a report and it says hey
no no uh activity of concern and it's
really really sensitive it'll pick up
almost anything it looks for keywords
Search terms and also
images
oh so sorry the actual story
is good
father discourages mortal
sin and sets a good example for his son
and then holds himself accountable in
front of his son so that his son knows
that he's not a
hypocrite subjects himself to the same
de demands moral demands that he's
making of his son and allows his son to
hold him him accountable if he were to
violate them so so the actual story is
this man is a good
father not doing weird sex stuff at all
and discouraging his kids from doing we
sex stuff and the absolute degenerates
these people at Rolling Stone who I have
to imagine have just burned out their
brains on such an extraordinarily High
degree of porn
consumption they the way they read that
is Speaker of the House Mike Johnson
admitted as though he what is though he
regrets this or something is this is
some dark confession he's encouraging
this he is promoting this in a public
forum admitted that he and his son
monitor each porn intake uh quite the
opposite actually they monitor each
other's lack of porn intake because this
man is a good father by all accounts
he's well formed and he's raising his
son in a good way in a resurfaced clip a
res like we we had to dig this one up
I'm sure Mike Johnson would talk about
this on the floor of the house this is
great so the actual story here is that
the current Republican speaker is an
excellent
parent and the and the story is is this
is weird or gross or evil in some
way woe to those who call good evil and
evil good amazing I I in a way I want to
give Rolling Stone the benefit of the
doubt I do suspect that on the physical
level their brains and perhaps on the
medical metaphysical level their souls
are so burned out by Vice and a failure
to
repent and an unwillingness to repent
that they just don't get it they don't
get that that's good that's you know
these Libs they say you should talk to
your kids about porn you should we
should have porn in elementary school
libraries we should encourage all sorts
of weird sexual behaviors uh no that's
the bad that's the bad creepy one that's
the bad if you want to be a good parent
but do what Mike Johnson's
doing speaking of our corrupt media
before we go for years now for years we
have heard that the war in Ukraine is
the most important important battle for
democracy ever that Ukraine which we all
thought of as a kind of corrupt
oligarchy former Soviet state it this is
the battle it's basically the 51st US
state all the American politicians need
to start wearing Ukraine Flags Slava
ukraini we will win we've got a if we
don't defeat Putin in Ukraine this will
be the World War II because Putin's
Hitler and he taking Czechoslovakia now
and he's going to take Poland and he's
going to he's
Hitler and then let just get this report
out from
NBC us and European officials have begun
quietly talking to Ukraine about peace
negotiations with Russia to end the war
this is according to one senior Us
official and one former senior Us
official which of course is happening
some of us have been saying for a while
now that at a certain point they're just
going to have to negotiate peace because
Ukraine cannot defeat Russia the United
States could defeat Russia if we became
hot Direct belligerant in the war we
could defeat Russia Ukraine cannot it is
not possible but they have that American
as their spokesman yeah that's not going
to help them but they have the the flags
you know on social media with the people
right that's not going to help them
either it is not possible for Ukraine on
its own or even with significant support
from NATO and from the United States to
defeat Russia on the battlefield it
cannot
happen so
finally American and European officials
are saying all right Ukraine negotiate a
piece what was the point of the last two
years more than two years at this point
what was the
point what was
achieved a lot of ukrainians
died and a lot of Russians died and you
actually heard some American politicians
talk about this they say oh this is
great we got to keep funding the war
Ukraine CU we're just killing off the
ruskis and that's really good we're just
killing them we don't even have to kill
them we just send the weapons and
Ukraine kills them and a lot of the
ukrainians die too but it's okay at
least we don't have to do
it but it's going to be the same result
that it would have been two years ago
they're going to negotiate a peace
they're going to give Russia some
territory they're going to agree not to
join
NATO they're probably going to agree not
to join the European
Union they'll they'll just probably be a
buffer State presumably zinsky will have
to be ousted if
possible they'll they'll end up almost
exactly where they were three four years
ago what happened to The Great Battle
for democracy imagine how
quickly The Narrative can
change we'll get to so much more there's
so much more that I want to get to but I
have to I have to be a teas because
we're on the road I'm here in itha itha
is gorgeous by the way Cornell was a
great deal of fun and they're going to
air that tonight I think on the YF
YouTube channel and then in the meantime
I'm Michael nlls this the Michael nlls
show see you
[Music]
tomorrow